ん
皆さんアウェイという学ご存じでしょうかこういうのなんか駄菓子屋さんとかで見た
ことないと言いませんでしょうかアオベエ緑米グアム
何度口の中が煽りなるためこれが噂のびっくり画面ほのか号館でみんな驚かそ
このアーべ緑便何かと言いますと食べると口の中が真っ青になるかもでございます止め
た方れていると思うんですけど
持っ
すごいですよ全然性愛ですねあっっ1枚は行きましたがないんですけどもう1回触れず
1個食べてみましょう
青竹食べます見た目を普通の玩具なんですよ普通のどんな風に食べると衝撃な色になっ
てしまいますいただきます
[音楽]
tano
bouvet てみました口の中を見てみましょうあああっっなんでなんだかあぁ
ファズアワーは半田いうというわけであの1個食べたらあっひっあああああなるんだっ
たらキュッとけどすごい
色になるんじゃないかやもうワンちゃんずっと多いんじゃないかやっぱりで俺はねあの
人と同じ7位やなぜや時でみんな赤いてね
下の色僕ぐらい青くていいんじゃないかと思いまして
客を食ったら来たがばんちゃん永続的に青になれるんじゃないかと思いまして今回青目
が部だけを100個連続で噛んでみたいと思いますその計画する中が何色になるかやっ
てみようじゃんじゃいただきます
頑張りますからねぇ
[音楽]
顎やべああああ
はいどゲートレズっ子管理みました10個食べたら口はこんな感じになりました
ん
air
待ってはマッハってこれどうすんの出港でこのレベルでしょ
あってまぁ俺はれたもしれないこれやっおっもどんどん顔死んだけどレジャーを食べ
ます
[音楽]
うううう
はいハーンズ個食べました奥津の予想を見てみましょう
[音楽]
せ by もうはみ出てるなぁ
あ
あまええこれうーんあのさっきより明らかに悪化してますね
なんかさっきはなんかもう青って感じだったんですけど今もう
[音楽]
なおんだこれ同然でこれ治んなかったらどうしてくれるのあのなんか全然おいしいん
ですけどあーこがきっつい
がブカブの僕だってもが部産直館だけですからねし追記セイモア子が痛すぎてちょっと
ヤバイ相撲70個がんばってみようと思いますでは
[音楽]
名前だガム噛みフィア
アジャライダー入っただけで50個食べましたあの
ガムの噛みすぎて本当に頭がイタイですやばい阿呆を頭も痛いって見てみましょう
はい
もうなんかベロじゃなくて唇が多くなってきましたねー
mir
これな温度かねさすがに30から50ティックは少ないですねもう結構上限に達したの
でしょうか
ただわかんないのはここからです残り50個くらいあると思うんで
残り50個でどのような変化ザってるのかこの馬一気に100まで行ってみようと思い
ますでは
[音楽]
me
やっぱ何やっていいですか
あ俺食べすぎたんや
はい
やばいぞやばいよー
ん
ai
me
dea
ana あああっ
はいというわけですいませんあの50個からもガンバッテクってみたんですけどあの
途中から変化がありませんでしょただで50個ぐらい食うと多分アウェーの限界まで
達してもう変化がなくなってきたんで
分
くん
塗りました
させしまう
おちんの鼻口のか